bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france comment ont évolué
selon vous les manifestations anti ball
sonar ou au brésil est ce qu'on peut
dire que le mouvement populaire a été
rattrapé par les politiques par la
gauche brésilienne bien on est dans une
situation qui est quand même assez
différentes de celles de la colombie qui
est actuellement victime de la crise
sanitaire de la crise économique crise
politique et donc il y à un espèce de
ras-le-bol qui déborde
l'institutionnalité au brésil ces
manifestations sont organisées par
l'opposition essentiellement par
l'opposition de gauche
dans un contexte où l'établissement
brésilien économiques financiers et
politiques traditionnels chouette
également le départ de jaillir ball
solaro qui se révèle qui s'est révélé
incapable de gérer la crise sanitaire
au nom de la perpétuation du maintien
d'une activité économique permettant à
la population de continuer à travailler
mais en réalité c'est l'inversé qui
s'est produit
et on assiste actuellement à des
fermetures de grandes entreprises au
départ de cadres étrangers
donc il y à une convergence entre un
regain de la gauche qui est porté par la
libération de l'ancien président lula et
l'opposition croissante de
l'institutionnalité brésilienne donc on
est là dans une période d'échauffement
dans tous les sens du terme
échauffement d'une population qui se
sent un peu perdu et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle les formations
politiques de gauche essaie de lui
apporter une réponse et échauffement
préparatoires c'est déjà le départ le
point de départ le coup d'envoi de la
campagne électorale présidentielle
j'ai la jaille arbas marron est
réellement fragilisé aujourd'hui est ce
qu'il risque la destitution puisque
c'était le mot d'ordre hier d
bin isa sion alors la destitution d'un
germe also narrow pourrait venir du
parlement il ya une commission d enquête
parlementaire qui fait un travail assez
redoutable pour le pour le président
dont on attend les conclusions et qui
pourrait effectivement produire conduire
à une destitution du président qui
serait accompagnée par les manifestants
d'hier mais qui ne sont pas qu'ils ne
seraient pas à l'origine de la
destitution présidentielle ce qui
surprend au brésil par rapport à la
colombie mais ça se rapproche peut-être
aussi de la situation du mexique
c'est la résilience du président molson
à rocky et comme vous le disiez maintien
quand même un socle important dans 24%
de soutien qui est le fruit de six
dernières années cinq dernières années
au cours desquelles l'établissement qui
aujourd'hui a changé d'avis à mener des
campagnes redoutable travers la presse
les réseaux sociaux de communication
pour déstabiliser le système de
représentation partisans du brésil donc
le président s'est appuyé sur les
églises évangélistes sur des des
communicants efficace en matière de
réseaux de communication et a joué sur
l'émotionnel donc l'opposition de gauche
essaie également de jouer aujourd'hui
sur sur l'émotionnel
donc on est dans un contexte assez
différent d'autres pays d'amérique
latine qui connaissent également des
problèmes de manifestations d'opposition
de rébellion qui sont la conséquence de
la crise sanitaire de la crise
économique et qui lui est lié donc on a
une situation particulière au brésil
pour foule ensemble comment réagit la
population brésilienne face à la
situation travers le pays alors la
situation le la population brésilienne
est un peu perdue donc le président
s'est comporté d'une manière totalement
irresponsable
donc il n'a pas proposé de stratégie
cohérente au niveau de l'état donc en
revanche dans certains états de la
fédération dans certaines villes
les responsables locaux ou régionaux ont
eu par exemple à sao paulo dans le nord
est du brésil dans d'autres régions du
brésil et il ya eu des vaccinations il y
a eu des recommandations de l'utiliser
des gestes barrières mais et sans
cohérence donc il pouvait y avoir par
exemple une ville où le maire recommandé
des mesures de protection gestes
barrières mais les maires de la
périphérie n'adoptait pas les mêmes
mesures
et encore moins au niveau fédéral le
président bodson arrow dans la
population est un peu perdu et elle est
d'autant plus perdu notamment dans les
milieux populaires que les églises
évangélistes c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement puissant extrêmement fort
au brésil non pas en pris position
depuis toujours soutiennent le président
ball somaro et considère que dans les
prêches de certains pasteurs de ces
églises la protection divine est
supérieur aux gestes barrières que
peuvent proposer certains à la
population brésilienne donc on a une
population qui est un peu perdu alors on
va voir si elle est parti de gauche
arrivent à remobiliser l'électorat
populaire mais ce n'est pas acquis
comme vous le disiez dans votre
l'information où vous avez donné tout à
l'heure il est encore 24% des personnes
qui soutiennent le président ball sur
noireau et c'est dans ces 24 pour cent
il ya un électorat populaire et
seulement important merci beaucoup pour
votre décryptage jean jacques
kourliandsky je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur à l'iris spécialiste de
l'amérique latine